Hey hi as actually just leaving Oh fine
okay thanks well here you are five
minutes too long on that conference call
and now you have to sit alone at lunch
you could go back and eat at your desk
but somehow that's even worse and your
usual lunch partners out with the boss
maybe if you stare at the other table
long enough they'll notice you Anna come
pull up a chair we can make room I need
to sit alone no it's okay there's no we
can make we can you know well that was
humiliating did you guys see Game of
Thrones last night you saw Game of
Thrones last night you have something
witty and intelligent to say about it
but that conversation is not for you you
can't join from the next table that's
pathetic time to pretend there's
something really interesting to look at
on your phone never mind you already
checked Facebook Instagram and Twitter
20 times today so there's nothing new
what is it about eating alone that makes
you feel like a loser no matter how old
you get no matter how confident you are
yourself one empty table and it's like
high school all over again
oh thank god oh you guy is he taken you
mean is this seat taken by anyone more
interesting oh yeah
now you have to make small talk with
someone you've never choose to eat with
under normal circumstances good you
can't even remember this guy's name
Ethan
Earl you know he works in the cubicle
across from you but beyond that nothing
so did you watch Game of Thrones oh
saying oh no I don't get HBO no of
course he doesn't
heaven forbid he actually do something
to contribute to the conversation now
he's just gonna sit there with his big
stupid face sucking on his big stupid
sandwich
well nothing left to do now besides pick
up the pace and end this nightmare and
salad huh
well back to the grind yeah yeah look at
them tiger ah thank god that's over
eating alone is the absolute worst
I like the part when you look on my ax
okay
you